hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trainsenses.com so i make this update
because i didn't do any update during
the weekend so i make this one just
before market open
uh so we're going to discuss amcgme and
what is happening in the global market
because we have some good signs for the
first time so it's not good enough to
say we are bullish but we have some good
signs listen till the end of the video
let's get into it all right i'll start
with amc daily timeframe bam bam so the
situation was that
we were having this oversold rsi we're
having this
uh hammer candle you know reversal
pattern this got followed by move up and
i told you guys that the resistance uh
area was first the strength line that
was previous support becoming resistance
it's not a usual way to use trend lines
but it's very accepted as long as you
see it's acting as resistance when you
come back to it here we got rejected
here again so here we broke out and
after the breakout we went to the next
one this one all right so right now
uh then on friday
minus eight percent
brutal move down as on the rest of the
market
no actually the rest of the market was
not that bad in the end we're gonna
analyze that but so here what happened
uh you can see what is happening we are
uh now stuck in this channel uh
logarithmic time frame for those who
want to do it uh use the 20-day moving
average that is here so the trend line
must be very close to it
so that it makes the level
uh the area
better
to make it a resistance area
so bam bam uh right now as you can see
we got rejected here found support here
guys so once again these trend lines
have not been touched and you can see
how well they are uh guiding traders to
buy and sell all right
so
what i can i say so this is still gonna
be the case guys for those who want to
grab some shares uh once again we're not
out of trouble we might go lower but we
have some good sense i'm going to show
you that you can just use this right
this trend line connect uh
april 11th
with
may 13th okay you realize you connect
those two points you're gonna have the
streamline logarithmic scale and here
it's gonna act as support if we go lower
uh then
uh on the way up if we break out here
same thing with volume increase as you
can see the volume is low so that's good
we can have another higher volume that
will trigger some algorithms some
traders so if we break out above 13.5
today tomorrow
um
then we're gonna need to adjust a little
bit uh it's gonna be bullish and we
might be we might have a nice move up so
this is the situation let me do gme and
stay with me until i finish triple q
guys because once again amc will not
rally without
um
relief on the rest of the market so
jamie jimmy is again as usual guys
doing this
you know sideways consolidation as it
likes to do
we have one more all right so
this is a typical gme
i would say
pattern
okay
it can last from two weeks to one week
one or two weeks usually
so
here are the trend lines let me add that
okay very clear guys nadi is support
and the resistance is even a bit lower
we have a resistance at 102 roughly and
then we have another one that is on the
medium term this is short term and on
the medium term it's rather 105 y 105
because we had here three reactions uh
yeah 105 is not a very strong level it's
more an area
yes here you can see one support
here i mean it's not that strong let's
be honest but it's still another
resistance that we have just above but
the short-term resistance is 102 so
basically you can consider that if you
close above 102 with volume increase
we're probably gonna keep uh going
higher on the way down as you can see on
amc
we have this downward sloping trend line
that is going lower so the support is
decreasing which is good if you want to
buy because you're going to buy lower
if
the time is passing
uh jme you're going to buy the same
level so it shows that jamie has
stronger technicals than amc to me as it
was before guys
sideways sideways sideways
down down down right
um that's the situation for now uh bears
are stronger on amc but whatever uh
whenever we're gonna bounce it's going
to bounce strongly on amc i believe that
uh so
here
yeah i'm pretty much done guys this is
the situation now stay with me i know
you guys like amc and gme
but you need to see that all right so
triple q i posted an alert this morning
in my discord it's not really an alert
it's more a situation and i was
explaining
that uh so we reached the 281 level i
had this level guys for
one month one month and a half
okay it has been hit perfectly i took
profit here yesterday on friday
a little bit higher i took profit at 59
on s triple q so roughly around where we
are right now all right so not that not
here i took profit roughly here right at
288 i took profit because i had a very
decent short position and i made very
good
profits so you know whenever you make
profits you just sometimes even if you
think you can make more you take profits
all right so that's what i did on friday
um i'm ready to reload
because there is still an ugly scenario
where we go much much lower so be
careful guys it's not the time to buy
the dip on stocks i got some questions
about tesla for example i wouldn't buy
tesla before 550
i'm not going to show the chart but just
a
number i wanted to give you so here what
the good news is that for the first time
we had a brutal move down the past four
days all right minus five percent guys
and yesterday we did
uh minus 3.5
minus four percent all right and i'm
okay three
during uh at the worst of the day so
usually those days that trade you know
that are very big moves you have an
increase in volume look at that guys
minus five percent on very low volume
that's good news it means that you know
bears are taking ground not because
they're stronger than buyers it's just
because
you know
buyers are just waiting
so
it's not a clean victory of theirs that
shows to me that bears are starting to
get you know out of steam
it's a little bit like a bullish
divergence but not on the momentum but
on the volume whenever you have a move
that is happening on decreasing volume
it shows that you know you can see the
volume like the ammunition so it's kind
of like in a war one camp is out of
ammunition
so this is good news to me that's the
only good thing i can see because
otherwise bears and full control of
course but this is an early sign of
reversal
uh we don't have the bullish divergence
yet i'm sure we have it on the four
hours time frame though
yeah not surprised because you can see
we go lower but right away we go higher
so this always creates bullish
divergences so on the forest we have a
bullish divergence but let's stay on the
daily on the day we don't have it but we
have this decreasing volume on the way
down here the volume was a little bit
higher but much lower than what we have
here so this to me looks a little bit
like the end of something all right
so this is why
i'm a little bit more positive than last
week
i took profit as well for this reason
when i saw this big volume
this big day on a low volume i was like
all right i'm gonna start to lock in my
profits
um and we're gonna be out of trouble not
hundred percent of course but with a i
you can see i increased this probability
from 50
to 55 percent and i'm going to increase
it to 70
if we have this breakout
so we need basically to close above 305
310 depending on what day it's gonna
happen today 310 in three days three or
five
uh i don't think we're gonna go at 310
today so let's call it three or five if
during the week you see a triple q
closing at three or five or higher it's
very positive especially if we have a
nice green volume uh when this happens
so guys pay attention to that and stay
with me stay with me until uh and we
have also some good signs of relief on
the indicators that we like to keep an
eye on u.s 10-year yield you remember
guys
285 was wow that's ugly okay let me get
rid of all of that
uh
285 was the level the breakout level we
are right now at 282 so it's not far it
can be some access but it's good to see
the yields you know just coming lower
i'm not going to explain again why it's
good but it's good all right
um
and also the xy i'm not gonna explain
again i did it 10 times if you want just
watch the videos i did one two weeks ago
i'm explaining that in all my videos at
the end when i discuss those indicators
and dx y
below than 103 so
less tension on the dollar market so we
have lower volume on the way down we
have the dx y below 103. we have us 10
yield below 285
and we just me we just need another
signal like a breakout or a strong
candlestick pattern so let's wait for it
and if this happens
guys
great things might happen on emc and gme
so we're gonna monitor all of that gme
needs to close above 102 amc needs to
close about 13.5 that's it for today i
hope you guys enjoyed this video and if
you did please don't forget to click on
the sub like and bell button so you're
going to be the first to know when i
upload anything new and stay close to
floor see you guys